they say he was a man obsessed chasing
memories faces sense yet amidst the
chaos he could only follow his heart hey
everybody it's Charlie this is gonna be
my first video for The Witcher TV series
if you don't know what's going on
Netflix greenlit a Witcher TV series
based on the novels those take place
before the story picks up during the
video game so if you played witcher 3 or
any of the other games then you have a
broad idea for the mythology but all
that stuff happens after what happens in
the books so i'll just do a brief
explainer for what's going on with the
status of the project is and when you
can probably expect episodes to drop but
remember it's Netflix so it takes a
little longer to premiere but they drop
all the episodes at once it'll probably
be 8 to 13 episodes which is usually the
range for the really big-budget series
like this but think of it as Netflix is
version of Game of Thrones so if you're
finding me for the first time be sure to
subscribe to get all the videos I'll do
videos for it the same way I would do
for Game of Thrones about the mythology
history videos character videos there's
so much that we can talk about it's
still relatively early in the
development on the project so it's not
like we're gonna be seeing episodes till
bare-minimum 2019 2020 it's gonna be a
big series but think about how many
years Game of Thrones or the Lord of the
Rings film series were in pre-production
before you actually got to see footage
of that stuff the showrunner Lorne his
rich just this morning as I'm posting
this video it's February 24th 2018
turned in her latest draft of the pilot
script to Netflix for notes they haven't
said how they're gonna produce the
series but it's probably gonna be the
same way they produced the Marvel
Netflix series or stranger things if
you're not familiar with the showrunner
she's coming off of daredevil in the
defenders so she's been spending most of
her time in the Marvel Universe
they didn't say whether or not they're
gonna start working on all the scripts
whether or not they're gonna hire a
writers room and start banging out the
rest of the episodes right away it
sounds like Netflix is just looking at
the pilot before they start casting the
actors and then they start hiring a
writers room to bang out the other
episodes but usually with Netflix once
they approve those first couple of
scripts and they find out what their
budget is going to be and they start
casting they just start making episodes
they don't wait for a pilot episode
before it green-lighting everything if
you have
a fan of the series for a long time
there was a movie in a TV series that
they tried to make in the early 2000s
there was a movie in 2001 then a TV
series that tried to tell that story in
13 episodes both were kind of regarded
as being bad by fans so you don't
absolutely have to watch those they
don't have anything to do with the
series that Netflix is doing think of
them like you would think of the really
bad Batman films like there's a really
popular character many different
adaptations some of the movies have been
good some of them not so good getting
into a little of the mythology there are
a couple really big things that they'll
probably hit during that first season
because it's taking place with the books
and if you're not sure what the reading
order is there's a series of short
stories then there's the main novels and
then there are a couple spin-off novels
and for the most part you can read those
in the order that they were published
because they're all chronological with a
few exceptions
so it's last wish sword of Destiny blood
of elves time of contempt baptism of
fire the swallows tower Lady of the lake
in season of storms but during that last
book season of storms they deal with
some prequel material so they jump
around in the timeline a little bit so
it gets a little confusing but just
start with the short stories then do the
blood of elves saga and then you can
read the spin-off books if you want for
the most part they're probably tackled
this chronologically Geralt of Rivia
as a child given to the school of the
wolf becomes a Witcher taking the
dangerous potions going through the
trials then developing serious storyline
who appears during most of the games so
you're probably familiar with most of
the characters that will pop up during
the novels and they'll do during the
series but because I imagine them doing
five to seven seasons I don't know if
he's going to meet ciri during the first
season or it's just going to be the
process of him becoming The Witcher I
don't know what the pacing is going to
be and how fast they're gonna burn
through the mythology
since the showrunner is coming off of
Marvel series daredevil defenders and
there's a big complaint about the way
they paced those hopefully they'll pick
that up with a witcher series and he'll
become a witcher before the end of
season 1 and we'll learn about the ciri
character maybe meet her in some fashion
so there may be time jumps they may do
his Witcher training in flashbacks so
they could actually do ciri on the show
because she sort of becomes his adoptive
daughter via the law of surprises but he
first learns about her
when she's still in her mother's womb so
it's kind of hard to do a character like
that on a TV show if you don't jump
around in time if you've only played
that last game then the Wild Hunt is
like the main antagonist of that series
the nipple guardian Empire is really
like the big bad of this epic saga of
stories so they slowly expand like the
Roman Empire I don't want to make too
many comparisons into Game of Thrones
because the mythology of both stories is
so different but this is probably one of
the coolest things about The Witcher
game series is that Charles dance Tywin
Lannister from Game of Thrones does the
voice for Emperor Amir during the
Witcher 3 your Imperial Majesty Geralt
of Rivia and cirilla Fionna Ellen
Rhiannon queen of sintra princess of
Bruges and Duchess of certain errors -
in Assad's Gaelic and innocence
colleague and suzerain of etre and Abbey
era Tyrion of the House Lannister stand
accused for the Queen regent of regicide
did you kill King Joffrey wouldn't it be
so cool if they could get him to play
that character on the TV series you
could make some Qyburn references
because he deals with things that seem
like magic albeit they're really science
that just isn't understood yet like
raising the dead back to life so during
the Witcher the trial of the grasses is
the process by which someone becomes a
Witcher while they're at the school of
the wolf the people there practise a lot
of genetic experimentation and a lot of
potion lore and created a process by
which to turn someone into a superhuman
witch Geralt did to gain all of his
superpowers in his abilities as a
Witcher so he trained to be a really
good fighter but in addition to that
took a whole bunch of crazy potions and
went through a bunch of experiments to
become something even more it gives him
enhanced abilities enhanced longevity
but it also takes some of his humanity
away from him like the more powerful you
get the less human you become the series
itself contains all manner of magical
creatures so you have everything from
vampires to dragons to demons
mages wizards witches all kinds of stuff
in while the niffle guardians are trying
to conquer the known world you also have
a lot of them
principalities that are warring with
each other which is a little bit like
Westeros before Aegon's conquest where
you have a bunch of different kings of
smaller States and then someone comes
along trying to conquer all of them
pretty safe bet that they're gonna
tackle some of the amir storyline if
you're not familiar with that Amir is
one of the princes of niffle Guard he's
cursed he changes into this really crazy
animal he's banished Geralt helps him
eventually
Amir falls in love with someone they
have a child that child is ciri but
because Geralt saved his life he's
granted a wish he invokes the law of
surprise that which you do not know
about yet and that is ciri in his wife's
womb so because series mother is a
source like she is someone that has
magical affinity ciri is like this
special child that has extra magical
affinity that girl then recruits to
become a future Witcher which is kind of
the funny way that they recruit people
to become part of The Witcher order like
it's not something that you sign up for
usually it's done through the law of
surprise like if they help save someone
and they just happen to have a child on
the way they invoke the law of surprise
which essentially makes them the ward of
this child so that's why ciri is sort of
like girl's adoptive daughter and then
obviously later in this series Aamir
becomes the Emperor of nipple guard
turns evil and starts killing a bunch of
people and becomes the antagonist of the
series like I said the nipple guardians
are the main antagonists of the entire
Witcher saga so the early short stories
in the early novels are really as much
about the origin of ciri as well as the
origin of Geralt so that's kind of how
I'm choosing to think about the series
like most people when they think about
The Witcher they think about corral but
you could argue that ciri is also just
as important because of her bloodline
and the way she's connected to the
Emperor of niffle garden good use to it
the for longevity soul from milk God to
the dragon mountains will kneel before
you I did not expect you to keep your
word with you so like I said if you've
seen any of my Game of Thrones videos
I'll be doing stuff like that for The
Witcher TV series but it's still so
early in the process that we're not
going to be seeing footage for a long
time so once we get more details about
who the cast is going to be and when
they're going to start filming and when
they're gonna pick up in the timeline
how they're gonna deal with some of that
back store
I'll do more videos but let me know if
you have any special requests or if
there's anything special that you want
me to do for a Witcher giveaway once
those regular videos start I'll start
doing that giveaway too but while you
wait for everything click here for
brand-new Game of Thrones and click here
for that brand new infinity war promo
thank you so much for watching everybody
stay awesome I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]